[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
britney spears soaks up some family time
with her sons sean preston and jaden
james and fiance sam eskari and gives
fans a rare look at their time together
it's fun for me on monday the 40 year
old pop star posted this clip of their
family outing on instagram
that's her 16 year old son sean and 15
year old son jaden whom she shares with
her ex-husband kevin federline having
fun together in a glow-in-the-dark room
at an interactive art exhibit
this is really well thought it's very
artistic okay so is this what your boys
room look like at home like your dad's
kind of brit and her man dance together
in the sweet clip and the 27 year old
model slash actor even pushes shawn on a
swing the main thing is to enjoy life
and take today take one day at a time
and i try to live by that and it kind of
it's kind of cool and the lucky singer
seemingly had a blast captioning the
clip quote adventures with the kids are
so much fun i'm really blessed
back in september britney revealed that
she asks her kiddos for permission
before she posts about them on social
media at the time she wrote that her
boys are quote extremely independent
little men adding quote there's a lot i
can't share with you all because my kids
are very private which i love but i will
tell you that they are both extremely
talented and i'm so incredibly blessed
to have these two little men in my life
and as brittany enjoys family time a
source recently told et that she is also
looking forward to a career comeback in
2022 and is actively eyeing different
brand deals and entertainment
opportunities quote britney is her own
decision maker now and she wants to
expand her professional horizons she's
just waiting for the right time for
everything what's next for brittany
and this is the first time this could be
said for about a decade is up to one
person
brittany
of course last month a los angeles judge
ruled to terminate the conservatorship
that has controlled the pop star's life
career and finances for 13 years could
you give me one word to describe how are
you both feeling now amazing and when it
comes to her relationship e.t source
says sam is a huge support for britt and
is encouraging her in every way she's
doing great i'm great i'm just it's the
happiest time of our lives and we're
just enjoying it et source previously
explained quote things are going very
smooth and steady for them as a couple
and if anything their relationship is
even stronger since getting engaged
the lovebirds got engaged in september
after nearly five years of dating and
when e.t chatted with brits man last
month he teased that wedding bells could
be ringing in the near future what's
going to be next well you know you
already know everyone knows already
sooner or later sooner or later what a
wedding
when do you want it to be sooner or
later yeah what kind of wedding do you
want to have what's your dream day you
know it's up to her she's wearing the
pants now
[Music]